all right I told you there was another
trailer I had to talk about so let's
talk about that trailer so this is the
second trailer for the Amazing Spiderman
and I like this trailer for the fact
that there are things in this movie that
I was looking forward to that I was
hoping we're in this movie and it
confirms that yes they are in it first
of all the Spidey sarcasm you come
you seriously think I'm the cop in a
skin-tight red and blue suit yeah for
those of you who don't know spider-man
is actually a little sarcastic when he's
taking down bad dudes so I'm glad that's
in it although at the end of that scene
he gives this really menacing look not
gonna live some guy webbed my arms to
the wall and gave me that look right
there I'd be like I'm gonna die yeah
he's got a funny before but now he just
looks like a murderer and a mask I guess
is why I don't steal cars it's actually
the only reason
another thing web-shooters I was glad to
see web shooters are in this movie I
knew they were gonna be in this movie
but I'm just a big believer in him
because spider-man is actually a really
brilliant kid so the fact that he built
these things shows that he's actually
really smart that he goes on Good Will
Hunting and completes that formula on
the chalkboard for dr. Connors yeah you
know smart dude which then plays into
the fact he actually helps create the
lizard you gotta assume that from the
trailer anyway sometimes trailers are
cut together to look like something
they're actually not but the fact that
he does that and then says to Gwen Stacy
assume he takes a hand in creating him
I'm just saying and Denis Leary's in
this movie as Gwen Stacy's father who's
hunting spider-man this guy wears a mask
like an outlaw I think he's trying to do
something maybe the police can't hint
which is a really good yet safe dynamic
to do in a movie you know the whole all
the heroes dating this girl the girl's
dad Edgar friendly from demolition man's
hunting the hero's been done but it
works not with Edgar friendly but you
know another thing I like is this shows
that Peter Parker really needs to hold
back because he's spider-man I mean if
any bully threw a basketball up against
his head he could destroy them but with
great power comes great responsibility
so I'm told I mean other than that the
trailers really exciting it has really
cool spider-man stuff that you want to
see my gripe about this trailer is that
it feels like he shows too much they did
not have to show you in this trailer
that Denis Leary issues a warrant for
spider-man I am issuing an arrest
warrant
for the masked vigilante known as
spider-man they didn't have to show you
the scene where he gets unmasked and
almost caught so he has to fight off the
cops without revealing his identity it
seems kind of insignificant but that's
like one of those things I'd rather just
see in the movie when I watch it show me
in the trailer it just feels like it's
showing too much I mean it's only
February the movie comes out in July so
there is another trailer that's coming
out what could they possibly show that
they haven't already shown and another
gripe I have about this trailer is that
sometimes Andrew Garfield looks as aged
Peter Parker supposed to be a teenager
in this movie Andrew Garfield was like
28 when he filmed it so sometimes he
looks like a teenager sometimes he looks
his age
maybe it's the glasses I don't know
maybe I'm just being an [ __ ] that is
possible in the end I like the direction
they're taking this spider-man movie I
like the tone I even like the suit a lot
of people hate the suit their like guys
whose [ __ ] me I have no problem with
the suit it is darker than the Sam Raimi
spider-man movies and maybe even a lot
of the comic books but I don't feel it
lost any of the spider-man feel to it
you know but all in all I do like the
trailer even though I still say I feel
like it shows a bit too much now I know
what you're thinking I know what the
question is the big question what do I
prefer the Avengers trailer or this
spider-man trailer very good question
sirs and ma'ams and I will answer for me
it's got to be the Avengers trailer I'm
a big spider-man fan I'm looking forward
to the spider-man movie - but there's no
moment in this trailer that made me go
dude blew my mind Loki and Tony Stark
don't talk in this trailer or anything
like that which I didn't talk about on
purpose cuz I wanted you to see it for
yourselves don't be a douche in any case
have you seen the new spider-man trailer
have you seen the Avengers trailer which
one do you prefer comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]